three hour right I don't want to order
my Thai food Ryan okay we're gonna do I
don't know I don't want that same thing
that's why yeah oh my god can you cancel
my food to them what happened what do
they Ryan's like you didn't even order
any Thai food call me dot type with two
days in a row it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter we should keep she was
literally in the middle of saying action
and then about to say it and blame it on
the alcohol news they met on the alcohol
got my ten years old now like okay
that's just still poppin dude go check
it out you know who's still making
[ __ ] big pink I bet Chingy [ __ ]
yang Yang Twins no drop my bow but they
never stop playing it yeah they never
paying the royalties whatever it spins
go and Spotify everywhere dude so if the
streaming is still going it's going it's
going
three more in the clock nope I'm saying
everybody [ __ ] plays that [ __ ] dude
still till this party Jen I don't know
do you think he didn't one of them
expose themselves I got a 102.7 no no it
was Casey and Jo Jo so not the 20 year
old reference okay
alder no that did not James Brown do
something yeah yeah yeah yeah Anna Duke
Ellington's you I believe Wow oh [ __ ]
damn that Louis Armstrong I know and I
remember a Beethoven did something to a
while back submitted by JT from NY
Justin Timberlake he's from Tennessee
yes different James it really it was a
country ass [ __ ] yeah done his
newest album it's all country well [ __ ]
okay well we know who's a fan here oh
yeah his birthday's January 31st 1980
was David favorite Justin Timberlake
song right now it's like that I don't
know
I can't big of a fan no fine here River
I didn't like him until he's really
Nelson dude a wedding photographer was
arrested during the reception for
erratic behavior which photographer a
wedding a wedding photographer erratic
behavior all Severson hobby was freak
dancing with their like breads mom why
do you think the photographer is a man
oh just because I don't have a video I
like that you say photographer by the
way yeah oh yeah you didn't do you spell
it if you are no I said photographer
okay that's it no I'm saying him why
think it's a man yeah why is it a man
that's just where my imagination what
yeah me too me too I usually see man vs
photographer sexist it is kind of bug
that's what we got first let me show you
she it was a woman she busted a titty
out she it was a woman yeah this is she
done the emolument okay so her name is
Catherine 26 years old from it's a woman
she's a wedding photographer and but
she's also shot some mood lights of the
bikini model she's hot
from this angle here she comes like
Angelina Jolie it's really dark so I'm
not sure that's okay well you know it's
really light yeah you know the Sun and
there's a nice titties yeah that's what
I'll say the real dude
separated along with the rubic power
boobs weird oh there's just a lot of
separation here but wouldn't send one of
you my way we are what are you in a
separation so there's like the cleavage
right like it should be closed there's
no like nice natural to it being here so
there's like force finger gap
oh there's indented gorgeous oh the jail
picture that's the next one okay so here
we go
she's in jail because they caught her
she's five foot five yes interrupting
what I was about to say was five six
okay so she was arrested her scrubs in
jail yep
I could jumpsuit maybe yeah like the
jail suit stuff it's amazing what like
that can do for somebody because those
other pictures she looked masturbation
worthy and all of a sudden they go don't
look where did she get arrested for what
is erratic behavior Oh hurry buddy
behavior was that she was having sex
with the guest in a room and then
someone caught them and as she started
to yelling at people
it started saying like your daughters
are gonna die oh she like hella wasted
yeah so they they were like and she also
said my dad is gonna find out about this
in y'all are [ __ ] dead
the e8d GED she just the person can
wedding yo and she was like y'all's
families will be dead by Christmas
ghetto y'all Oh y'all's family on top
outside y'all fam you [ __ ] deep oh
this is Texas yes then when they
arrested her on by the way he also peed
on a tree it was the main thing why
don't you want to kill him during
Thanksgiving that's [ __ ] up who's that
Thanksgiving Christmas by Christmas so
Thanksgiving happens before Christmas so
during that time when families together
she's plotting to kill them during
Thanksgiving that's why they'll be dead
before Christmas Wow red string of
thoughts just connected right there and
so when they arrested her they found in
her pockets a prescription of xanax
and our jacket it's always that sound
they believe that she mixed alcohol with
xanax but then will you her sister is
saying that nah she's a trifling [ __ ]
no she's saying that she got sick while
she was working at the wedding because
she drank and then she unlocked
knowingly drank a spiked drink oh is
what the sisters think damn what a good
sister beckon her yeah and unless she
went outside and that these two men
tried to approach her and do
inappropriate things and as she was
yelling and trying to get help but then
things turned around in a negative way
so it's like she got quaalude in at the
wedding reception Cosby we know but
that's not I don't think that's how
quaaludes work right cuz like she said
cuz they can't exist anymore but she was
she was [ __ ] in a dressing room
cursing people out while she was
gathering Hersh I don't think that's
what quaaludes do right isn't it
supposed to make you like super like
loose and anxiety yeah but she's saying
she got quaalude yeah her sisters saying
Mike did but that's not true is it well
we don't know no we don't have that
technology test or anything if that was
my wedding and this happened to me the
first thing I would do is look at the
pictures if those photos were amazing
I'll be like thank you this memory was
[ __ ] dope cuz you could just not
forget about that I could forget about
it by the time I'm 90 years old and me
and my hunt is looking at our beautiful
wedding pictures I'll be like it was all
worth it because these pictures are
amazing
mmm-hmm because because what if this
wedding photographer was like super like
well-mannered and all that and you had
the shittiest [ __ ] photos I would be
mad yeah she gets a pass if the photos
are good yeah so she gets the pass yeah
even though she caused all that
disruption yeah
today I know but he's saying though if
the creatures are good ugly ass [ __ ]
photos and they're the most polite
Pleasant person yep or would you rather
have obscene person but the best father
have the day have beautiful memories you
can't have everything - yes I can
we'll be taking photos so I have cat
photos from there let me let me ask you
this let me ask ya you go to a concert
okay and you know you know how musicians
are they're crazy they're doing coke
they're defecating in the [ __ ] green
room they're crazy
right best show ever the performance was
amazing you would you rather have that
or a well-mannered artist that goes on
stage example she doesn't get affected
wanna see by the first one well you own
the you own the hotel or whatever it is
you all gotta talk you gotta clean up
the Dookie okay what you have to do it
if it's a good show do it all day you
hear that sweet sound in your ear and
you're like that but this is nasty but
it was worth it but you like [ __ ] you
admitted you like okay boy I want some
good I would like the good pictures yeah
I'd give her a pass for the good photos
she says she's a mom too but I don't
know can't redo the marriage the wedding
that's all right I didn't notice the
boob separation I didn't notice it now
what about the guy in all of this what
about that I know it's nobody blamed the
guy the guy look I wasn't [ __ ] going
off the guy wonder who the guy is what
they stepping in on her having sex in a
room I was on accident because what if
it was their bedroom she got all the
photos she needed that day the bounce
[ __ ] it's obviously sex time though
sure he got all the pictures by
transferring for this time in the let
you take pic like the weddings right let
you take pictures when the bride and
groom are still like coherent right once
they're all I'm holy listen they're
[ __ ] mess there's money you don't
want no pictures of that here
OSHA's next time I think where she
[ __ ] up and she got so embarrassed
that she started like cussing at them
and threatening spells what she should
have done is been like man I was so
inspired by y'all love and and it just
really made me wet like the love I felt
it through the camera and I couldn't
hold myself back and I had a [ __ ]
haven't you seen the wedding singer yeah
how did you see wedding crashers Oh
wedding crashes that scene where all the
girls fell on the bed and all the
titties [ __ ] up one of the best movie
scenes ever dude I [ __ ] loved it what
was that movie about he crash weddings
we crash weddings to pick up on girls I
thought they're trying to figure out
what's the best mattress to follow
that's why I thought to you okay what's
the best mattress of the world that's
right oh that's right with isla fisher
do either fishers [ __ ] hot dude yeah
that's why I don't want to bring people
around that I don't know I don't it's
weird you know to me like I got to get
to know them I got to filter these
people out before I bring them in before
she was hired that's what I'm saying
though you can't trust everything so
bird they hired you to take pictures
right stay sober throughout that whole
time do your job how about that
then afterwards party drink some
champagne then we know I still think you
should be professional and just if you
want to kick it drink if you know you
have issues with your alcohol do that
after you win you're home you're there
to do your job but they but they always
ask you to stay though you know when
you're like you know hey I'm done I got
all the pictures I needed the bride and
groom laws you should you should just a
kiss there the whole time to me well he
wasn't technically keep it in hiring me
therefore just as a favor yeah yeah but
French people are also different the
point is this Medea is so sucky and the
[ __ ] boss is different you know I
mean I think we know French people very
well
[Music]
[Music]